hello and welcome to those of you who
are new to one dream and the great
courses and welcome back to all of you
who joined me for my original lecture
series on the black death which appeared
in 2016.
over the next seven lectures i'm going
to share some exciting new information
with you about recent scientific
discoveries that shed more light on that
14th century pandemic known as the great
mortality or the black death
and i'm also going to talk about what
we've learned about pandemics over the
past couple of years as the world has
been struggling
with covet 19.
when i was taping the last lecture
series in late 2015 some fascinating new
information about the black death was
just starting to appear in print in
academic journals scholarly monographs
and scientific papers at precisely the
moment we were too far along in the
process to include as much of it as we
would have liked although we did get
some information in at the 11th hour
since that time however there has been
an absolutely exponential growth in
terms of the number of discoveries and
indeed evidence that shows that some of
what we thought we knew about the black
death was completely wrong
even had the covid 19 pandemic not
erupted in the way it did it still would
have been necessary to do this follow-up
series of seven lectures to share new
information and correct past
misunderstandings
but of course in the age of kovid
understanding this past pandemic has
seemed more relevant and important than
ever
i will be the first to say that i
thought
i could appreciate not completely but to
a significant degree i thought i could
appreciate how terrifying and horrific
it must have been to live through what
has long been considered the first wave
of the black death from approximately
1346 to 1353.
in march 2020 i was having a
conversation over zoom as i imagine many
of us were with some of my friends from
college one of whom is a doctor in the
bay area
where as we all know covet hit hard in
the early days of the pandemic
we started discussing mortality rates
that is
of the people who contract a disease
what percentage of those who are ill
will die
at that point in time covid mortality
rates were hovering around two percent
and hospitals were filled to capacity
with people who were very very sick from
the disease
so many of my friends who are doctors
were working multiple shifts
and quarantining away from family in
order to protect their loved ones
on this particular zoom call my friend
asked me
what mortality rates were during the
black death
what percentage of the people who
contracted plague would die from it
best guess i said
around 80 percent
18
she said in horror there's no way
society would have utterly collapsed
and then i had to tell her that no i had
not said 18
what i had said was
80 percent
there was utter silence among the four
of us on the zoom call as my friends
absorbed this piece of data
so another friend asked what percentage
of the population actually died
for europe i said estimates are that at
least 50 percent of the population was
wiped out
and in that moment the horror of the
black death struck me harder than it
ever had before
because while kovid was and is
absolutely terrifying at least in the
modern age we have things like drug
therapies and ventilators and we
understand how viruses and bacteria can
be transmitted and we can take steps to
try and prevent or reduce transmission
people in the medieval european world
had none of that
and as we'll see
plague was also circulating and
devastating populations beyond the
borders of europe during the middle ages
and as far as that data i gave my
friends on that zoom call in march 2020
i was probably underestimating
mortality rates during the black death
were more likely closer to 82 percent or
85 percent
and the overall impact on the population
was probably more severe with something
like
60
and in some places as much as 70 percent
of the population wiped out
and while my information was generally
correct for europe
one new piece of information that we're
going to explore in depth is this
it now seems clear that the black death
was in fact a global pandemic
extending much further into africa in
the middle east and circulating through
much more of asia than we first believed
not only that
new research suggests that it was
circulating in some places at least a
century
before the european wave that burned
through the population of that continent
from 1346 to 1353.
one reason that these cases of plague
beyond the medieval european world have
seemed largely invisible until recently
is that there have been very few
scholars who have the skills to
understand letters
legal documents and diplomatic reports
from this time period from both medieval
western sources and the mongolian or the
muslim world
i've gotten many emails from people
since the first lecture series asking
about what was happening to the east of
the medieval european world were people
dying at the same rate as they were
further to the west
how were those societies impacted and
usually the answer i give is that since
this is beyond my main area of expertise
i'm not really sure
scholars like me who were trained to
read latin or old french
usually don't have facility with primary
sources that might have been written in
persian or arabic or mongolian and until
recently scholars from these different
traditions haven't usually been sharing
resources or pooling their skill sets
in just the last few years this has
started to change
and scholars such as nuket varlik hannah
barker and especially monica green whose
name you are going to hear a lot in the
lectures ahead have been able to gain
access and share information among
scholars who work on the same period but
focus on very different communities and
languages
particularly dramatic evidence of this
comes from a groundbreaking article
titled the four black deaths
written by professor monica greene and
published in the prestigious academic
journal the american historical review
at the end of 2020
this interchange of information has
opened up a whole new world of discovery
we are going to dig more deeply into
this article and many other significant
contributions made to black death
studies by professor greene and many
many others since we made the previous
course in the lectures to come
additionally ollie benedicto long
considered the top plague scholar in the
world in early 2021 released a massively
comprehensive new edition of his 2004
book the black death the complete
history
in this new and enormously expanded
edition benedicto addresses and includes
the new research and discoveries that
have occurred since the appearance of
the earlier edition of his masterwork
and in case you're wondering what i mean
by enormously expanded
here's the old edition and you can see
how thick it is which clocks in at a
respectable 433 pages
and here
is the new edition
which at
1026 pages is about two and a half times
larger
the 2021 edition is so large that twice
while traveling i have had my bag pulled
for a check while going through security
as the scanners would flag this book
because it was so large and didn't
really look like a typical book
and of course i've got some funny looks
from the tsa when they opened my bag to
find a giant book called the black death
taking up a huge amount of real estate
in my carry-on
in addition to these new discoveries and
interpretations of primary source
material
what we understand about the black death
has been greatly advanced by new
scientific discoveries concerning the
genetic makeup of yercenia pestis
innovations in medicine and science have
made it possible for us to actually look
at the dna of bodies recovered from
plague pits
what scientists call a dna or ancient
dna
and we can compare the results in order
to determine if what was causing the
great mortality throughout the medieval
european world was the same disease and
in fact the same strain of the disease
every place we can test for it
and the answer turns out to be
yes
indeed one very important article that
discusses how scientific advances have
been used to great result by scholars in
the humanities working on plague is
entitled historians in lab coats
so whereas prior to this scholars
primarily relied on eyewitness and
first-person accounts from plague
stricken areas with a little bit of
scientific and medical knowledge cited
to shore up and affirm the major claims
now it is the science that black death
scholars need to understand first
in order to make sense of what the
documentary evidence tells us
in many cases we can now see that we
must take many of the claims from
primary documents with a grain of salt
humans then and humans now are prone to
hyperbole and exaggeration
so some details that we've relied on as
solid evidence need to be looked at a
bit more skeptically but at the same
time the general picture we get from
these sources is confirmed
this was indeed
the world's most devastating plague
and the death
trauma and suffering endured by those
who lived through it
still
almost exceeds our ability to grasp and
imagine it
so between this lecture series and the
original one we have learned so much
about plague that a lot of beliefs that
we've previously held and which i told
you about at great length
need to be corrected amended or thrown
out because they are just plain wrong
so what was it that i and other scholars
were wrong about
well for one thing the geographic and
temporal origin of the outbreak of the
pandemic we now call the black death
earlier i told you that most scholars
have long agreed that climate change in
hubei province in what is today china
drove an infected rat colony out of
their habitat and into contact with
humans probably sometime in the 1330s
and from there plague moved westward
with great rapidity
nope
as i'll explain at greater length in a
future lecture the wave that entered the
medieval european world actually erupted
somewhere near the volga river basin in
the 1330s
and that outbreak it turns out was not
the major event that produced the second
pandemic to begin with
in a later lecture we'll discuss at
length what scientists are calling the
big bang of yercenia pestis
and they've pinpointed that this event
happened about a century earlier than we
thought
somewhere around 12 50.
and it was not in hubei province that
this occurred but rather
further west near the tianshen mountains
and the mongolian steppe
from there it began to circulate
centrifugally moving both east into
china and west into europe
this is why you see an outbreak in hubei
province in the 1330s and the beginning
of the outbreaks in the medieval
european world just a decade later
the plague was coming out of a point
between europe and asia and moving into
both territories at roughly the same
time
so what else did i accidentally get
wrong
well
the biggest disappointment for many of
you may be the story of the siege of
kapha
you may recall that mongols supposedly
catapulting plague infected bodies into
the city from whence it infected genoese
sailors who then brought it home to the
italian peninsula
it turns out that that story is super
duper wrong
as i'll tell you later that siege in
fact delayed the entry of plague into
medieval europe
don't worry if this sounds confusing i
will explain at great length
in the earlier lecture series i also
talked about numerous theories that it
wasn't just plague circulating in the
medieval world rather
many scholars have thought that there
might have been other diseases
circulating simultaneously which is why
the death count was so incredibly high
anthrax tuberculosis
typhoid and the rather fringe theory of
particles from space among others
have all been floated and at this point
in late 2021
were pretty sure that it was almost
exclusively plague that was responsible
for the body count
here ancient dna analysis has helped us
put that question to rest and i'll tell
you all about that a little further down
the line when i explained that we now
understand the primary vector of
transmission
the bite of an infected and infective
black rat flea
this is still the number one way to
contract plague
another reason to return to this topic
now is because plague remains a real
threat in the modern world not least of
all because it is considered by the us
government to be a disease that could be
weaponized
side note here
about three years after i had done all
the research and writing and taping for
the first lecture series on the black
death
my father just happened to casually
mention
that when he was in the navy and sent to
vietnam he and the rest of his aircraft
carrier crew were all given a
vaccination against bubonic plague
i know nothing about how efficacious it
might have been nor does he
but at the moment there is no plague
vaccine in existence although the u.s
government is concerned enough about
plague and its potential weaponization
to have websites dedicated to answering
questions about it
the concern about weaponization of a
disease also seems particularly apt for
discussion during the age of covid as we
all well remember that when the coven 19
virus first appeared
many people theorized that the outbreak
was due to human error or perhaps even
deliberate action that the virus had
escaped or been let loose from a lab
other theories pointed to contact with
certain animals bats perhaps that had
somehow manifested as a zoonotic episode
leaping from animals to humans
in recent years we've seen plenty of new
and terrifying diseases make this jump
west nile virus and zika virus for
example
in our modern globalized world as
climate change brings heretofore unknown
diseases into closer proximity with
humans
we should be paying close attention to
whatever lessons we can draw from kovid
and especially we should be considering
them in light of what we now know about
the black death
one thing that has become clearer as we
compare the after effects of covid with
those of the black death is that during
and after a pandemic of this scale
society will experience serious upheaval
social political economic religious and
cultural unrest are all things we
discussed as regards the outbreak of the
black death
but as we examine the black death in
light of covid what seems more likely is
that the outbreak of a true pandemic
simply reveals flaws that we already on
some level
knew were present in our society and it
then exacerbates them to such an extent
that it may feel like the whole world
has come unmoored from its foundations
and as i'll discuss toward the end of
this series of seven lectures
when this happens
we see humans turn in any number of
predictable and very unpredictable
directions
as they seek some sort of stability
and constancy
now one thing that i did not unwittingly
mislead you about in the first lecture
series was the fact that for people who
survived the black death
after a significant adjustment period
pretty much everyone was better off than
they had been before and humanity
underwent several improvements and
advancements
we have yet to see what the final
outcome of the covet 19 pandemic will be
but as i write these words in november
2021 we are seeing a surging demand for
labor just like we did in the wake of
the plague and concomitantly wages
rising in an attempt to attract more
people back to the workforce
but while there may be some positives we
can hope for
the experience of covid helps drive home
for us what the human cost of those
advances and improvements really
entailed
starting around 1353 sure there was
plenty of land for the taking there was
increased upward social mobility the
general population was better nourished
and better educated
but those well-fed newly literate
suddenly land-rich people had also
experienced an unbelievably traumatic
event
not only that
but it was a trauma that would keep
returning every 12 to 15 years or so
until 1721
while there is hope that we are reaching
the end of the major outbreak of
coronavirus it remains to be seen if we
are in the middle of the ride rather
than at the end
so now let's get to it and turn our
attention to what we now know was the
single most important factor in the
spread of plague
black rats and their fleas